in today's video from free pilot
training i've got a really important
lesson for you on how to use the
altimeter you're probably going to see
questions about this on your oral and
your written exam so stick around and
let's knock out some studying
so check this out take a look at the vfr
day minimum equipment requirements in
far 91 205. if you'll notice you have to
have an altimeter anytime you fly an
airplane under visual flight rules and
if an altimeter is that important to vfr
flight you should definitely know how to
use it and that's what this lesson is
about today but before we can talk about
how to use it there's a couple things we
need to talk about first let's start by
talking about the different types of
altitude we have indicated altitude true
altitude pressure altitude absolute
altitude and density altitude
indicated altitude is just like it
sounds it's whatever your altimeter is
reading
and this is true regardless of what your
altimeter is set at so the indicated
altitude on this altimeter is 625 feet
msl it's important to note that
indicated altitude is not always
accurate our real altitude is called
true altitude and this is our actual
height above sea level
now in a perfect world we'd want our
indicated altitude to match our true
altitude and while it's pretty rare to
get them to match perfectly we're going
to talk about how to get them as close
as possible here in just a minute
next we have absolute altitude and this
is simply our airplane's height above
the surface and we express this in agl
and even though your true altitude might
stay the same your absolute altitude
will go up and down with the terrain and
unless you have a radar altimeter you'll
have to calculate this if you want to
know your absolute altitude it's not
that hard to do though all you have to
do is subtract the ground elevation from
your true altitude
for example let's say i'm flying at a
true altitude of 2500 feet msl if i fly
over this airfield in lawrence kansas
that has an elevation of 833 feet all i
have to do is subtract 833 from 2500
and this gives us an absolute altitude
of
1667 feet agl
the next type of altitude that you need
to be familiar with is called pressure
altitude
pressure altitude is the height of
something above the standard datum plane
this is an imaginary line that we draw
where the air pressure equals 29.92
inches of mercury but remember 29.92
inches is only the average so this line
can be above sea level sometimes it can
also be below sea level but it's rarely
right at sea level and when it is we
call this the standard day
now you can get your altimeter to read
pressure altitude by spinning this
little knob until the kohlsman window
reads 2 9 or 9 or 2. and with the
altimeter in this configuration it's now
telling you your height above the
standard datum plane well why do i care
about this
well at higher pressure altitudes the
performance of your airplane is
significantly reduced and this is mostly
due to the lack of oxygen which helps
your engine produce power
and while your true altitude may not
actually be that high if your pressure
altitude is then your aircraft still
might not perform the way it should the
next type of altitude that you need to
be familiar with is called density
altitude this is pressure altitude
corrected for non-standard temperature
as you're probably already aware at
lower altitudes the air molecules are
more tightly packed together this
creates a higher static air pressure at
low altitudes but as the temperature
rises this pushes the air molecules
apart which lowers the air pressure from
the ground all the way up to the top of
the atmosphere so because of that when
you have high temperatures you get two
big problems
low air pressure means poor aircraft
performance
first there are less air molecules for
the propeller to push the aircraft
forward
that means there are also less air
molecules for the wings to create lift
engine performance is also decreased and
that's because there's less air for
combustion
and if you're looking for a way to
remember when your airplane won't
perform the way it should remember the
four h's high hot heavy and humid
anytime you're at high air pressure
hot temperatures heavy aircraft weight
or it's humid outside your airplane
performance could suffer so just so
you're not confused density altitude is
based on pressure altitude and
temperature and this is how we calculate
aircraft performance that being said
indicated altitude is also affected by
temperature
the other problem associated with hot
temperatures is altimeter air your
altimeter is calibrated to 15 degrees
celsius that's about 59 degrees
fahrenheit and there's no way to account
for these temperature changes on your
altimeter that's why it's so hard to get
your true altitude to match your
indicated altitude so that means at
temperatures above 15 degrees celsius
you'll have lower air pressure which
means that at temperatures higher than
15 degrees celsius you'll be higher than
you think at temperatures lower than 15
degrees celsius you'll be lower than you
think
so right now you're probably thinking
okay hot temperatures i'll be higher
than i think that's really not a big
deal worst case i can do a forward slip
or something to get myself down quicker
but at temperatures lower than 15
degrees i'm lower than i think i am and
you can see how this could be a problem
when you're coming in for a landing
especially if you're working on your
instrument rating and you're not able to
look outside
so how can i know exactly what altitude
i'm flying at when i'm in these
conditions
this particular chart comes from the
pilot's handbook of aeronautical
knowledge but you can also get this
chart in the aim in chapter 7-3-1
let's say i'm at 2000 feet agl and the
temperature is negative 10 degrees
outside as you can see from this chart
our true altitude is 200 feet lower than
our indicated altitude and you can see
if you're in the weather how scary this
could be now it's not always going to be
practical to pull out this chart anytime
you're flying in cold weather but you
just need to be aware that when it's
colder outside you're lower than you
think you are now that you have a better
understanding about the different types
of altitude let's talk about how we can
adjust the altimeter so the indicated
altitude is as close to true altitude as
we can get it
to do this you'll want to spin this
little knob until the kohlsman window
reads the air pressure reported at the
airfield now what i'm about to tell you
next is not usually explained very well
but i believe it's important to
understanding how the altimeter works
remember the other day how i told you
that air pressure changes one inch of
mercury every thousand feet
now this is true and because of that the
altimeter is able to sense what altitude
you're at and give you a reading but
when you get the pressure reading from
atc or some other official aviation
weather source you're not actually
getting the pressure reading at the
field if this were the pressure reading
at the field and you were to put that in
your coldsman window your altimeter
would actually read zero and that's
because these pressure readings are
corrected for elevation that way your
altimeter knows exactly what altitude
you're at and because of that the
altimeter knows that we're at a thousand
feet msl because it's sensing a pressure
of
29.12 inches of mercury that's why if
you know your field elevation you can
actually spin that in instead of an
altimeter setting because what you're
doing is you're saying i know i'm at 625
feet msl so my pressure must be
29.90 inches of mercury
that being said getting an accurate
altimeter setting is the preferred
method and that's because in order to be
accurate with the other method you need
to know the exact elevation of that spot
you're sitting on when you make the
adjustment
all right now that you've got that down
let's talk about flying in areas of
different air pressure let's say i take
off from an airfield where the altimeter
setting is 3018 and i fly to another one
where it's 2918
so remember pressure decreases as we
increase our altitude so these higher
numbers mean that we're in an area of
higher air pressure
and we're flying over here to an area of
lower air pressure one inch of mercury
to be exact and if you remember from
earlier that's a thousand foot pressure
difference so you can see how this could
be a problem if you don't update your
altimeter setting when you fly from one
airfield to the next
okay let's say we took off and we
climbed a 2000 feet msl with an
altimeter setting of 3018
and we spun that in because that's what
they were reporting at the field so now
what the altimeter does is it gives you
the pressure difference between that
number and what it's sensing in this
case it's sensing 2818 so it's giving
you a reading of two thousand feet
okay so let's say we fly closer to the
field and we still have three zero one
eight set so now what the altimeter is
doing is saying i'm still sensing two
eight one eight so i must still be at
two thousand feet because he has the
field pressure set at three zero one
eight and that's a difference of two
inches of mercury but in reality we know
that the altimeter is two nine one eight
so that's a thousand foot closer to two
eight one eight so we're a thousand feet
lower than we think we are and we're
only at a thousand feet msl
so now to help you remember that i'll
tell you that age old saying from high
to low look out below and if that's true
the opposite is as well from low to high
high in the sky
before we leave here today i want to
leave you with one more important piece
of information that might end up being a
test question
the bigger the numbers that you put here
in the coldsman window the higher the
altimeter will read
and that's because it's taking the
difference between where you tell it sea
level is in that area and what it's
sensing
the higher the pressure is at sea level
the bigger the difference will be
between that and what the altimeter is
sensing and that means you'll be at a
higher altitude
i hope you enjoyed today's video please
be sure to hit the like button and
consider subscribing before you check
this one out right here